hi guys we're on our way and it's saying
now it's gonna take us over an hour
we've already been in the car for like
at least 225 minutes well it did stop
with Starbucks first
I got the your mom I got an iced
americano what you got it I got coffee
Frappuccino a little bit of espresso
like two extra shot we are heading to
you the dirty thirty premiere very
excited for a girl great and Hannah and
mamrie computer on I think that's
incredible
that's Riley that's for Sally okay
you're just taking off cause you got all
those extra something bathroom
succesfully yours mm-hmm that was a sec
that's who this is true so here we go
we're gonna get there it's uh here by 40
currently 540 at least we have a really
good view we have the beautiful plants
in front of every two hour and eight
minutes we'll check in with you guys in
a bit it's about an hour later it's
currently 6:30 we've been in the car for
a really really really long time this is
unreal
yes it's my anytime there's any movie
premieres or something downtown and
you're coming from the West Side
Hollywood downtown I don't know I don't
know we're going leave very early think
we should have left it two o'clock what
are you two left five hours early to get
there because I always know that there's
traffic in LA but this is a lot this is
a lot just see and think there might
have been a few accidents and there's
like a fire we passed yeah there's a
huge fire at 10:00 a smoke coming out of
the building this is nuts
oh we're going to get there yeah we may
miss most the movie but work we're on
the way love and support we love those
guys I'm debating whether whether I'm
gonna pee myself or not
maybe a little bit of trouble here look
at this beautiful sunset so pretty so so
pretty didn't think I'd be seeing the
sunset from whatever road this is the
highway update its 703 I'm fitting the
car since I don't even know it's dark
out the bathroom all the coffee has been
drank like I'm sweating I'm sweating
bladder at all
we're almost there we're so close
is that glass hey what's that what side
of the street does it say it is okay
okay okay it's not the right right
nervous this one is why this one I
decide that your side
okay okay little bit of yellow but
that'll yellow then okay split okay go
going down going down
we made it into two and half hours I'm
going to die
we've the IATA piece awake theaters and
restaurants on p2 no no we're here in
Casio saving us a seat so we at least
privacy yes okay w7 stuff right there I
don't want to have to be with Boulevard
that's the last thing that I wanna have
to do you literally just took that
elevator rip those doors open I don't
figure so we're here okay
[Music]
I think you're gonna get a pretzel
probably do that she's and although he
gets the red part back the movie no
we're here time community and is the
back of the time so all is well and I'm
excited to see all of the habits and all
the way I felt like a party and it feels
like we sent out the invitations a year
ago and we've just been anxious for
everyone to show up and throw down so
I'm gonna pass it's great because I have
a vodka soda backstage here's the main
here enjoy the movie will see you at the
after-party we're now at the after party
I let me tell you that this water is so
good it was really really funny it was
really good yeah I loved so much and FBI
friends look
TV's the tree just like in the movie
alert it was really good I mean like I
knew it was gonna be funny cuz it's
great and Hannah yeah but like it
surpassed the funny level that I was
expecting yeah
this is also a spoiler alert
[Applause]
so I always forget to end my vlogs for
some reason so I just want to say hi and
bye
dirty 30 was such a good movie actually
I have a little dirty thirty gift box
downstairs let me go grab that that'll
be a good end to this vlog no wonder
what could be in here
I hope there's something that I could
eat cuz I haven't had breakfast yet
toilet paper a party cup a thumb cool
just what I needed
oh my goodness I've already got the DVD
viewing party oh my gosh there's okay
well nothing I can eat but something I
can drink very very cute
I'm gonna go and finish out this video
so I'll see you guys later bye I think
we're in luck one of the most important
things is you want to spring your pan I
don't know if you saw the video that I
did for my sister's birthday we tried to
make a birthday cake and something she
didn't do was spray the pan enough
you gotta spray it good but if it says
no stick I spray it anyway
you will not
[Music]